RACHEL: WELCOME BACK TO "FOX &
FRIENDS", TEXAS GOVERNOR ABBOTT
ISSUING NEW EXECUTIVE ORDER
ORDER RESTRICTING TRANSPORTATION
OF MIGRANTS WHO MAY BE AT RISK
OF SPREADING CORONAVIRUS.
NOW ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND IS THREATENING TEXAS WE
WILLINGAL ACTION IN A LETTER TO
THE GOVERNOR WRITING, THE ORDER
IS BOTH DANGEROUS AN UNLAWFUL
AND VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW IN
NUMEROUS RESPECTS AND TEXAS
CANNOT LAWFULLY ENFORCE THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
IS THIS SETTING A DOUBLE
STANDARD FOR COVID PRECAUTIONS?
WELL, WE ARE GOING TO ASK HOST
OF JUSTICE WITH JEANINE.
JUSTICE WITH JEANINE.
SO TELL ME, THIS IS A PRETTY
MILD THING TO SAY, HEY, MAYBE WE
SHOULDN’T LET ILLEGALS WITH
COVID GO THROUGH TEXAS?
JEANINE: THIS IS A CLASSIC
SHOWDOWN BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL
AS THE FACT THAT YOU’VE GOT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
LAYING DOWN THE WELCOME MAT FOR
ILLEGALS.
THEY ARE LITERALLY TRANSPORTING
THEM AND THIS PRETTY MUCH ROSE
OUT OF THE FACT THAT THEY GOT
COVID-INFECTED ILLEGALS AND
LAYING DOWN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THE WELCOME MAT
AND TAKING THEM TO NONGOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION, CATHOLIC CHARITIES
TO A HOTEL.
THEY ARE COVID INFECTED AND THEY
DON’T HAVE A COURT DATE, THEY
DON’T HAVE A MEDICAL
APPOINTMENT, THEY DON’T HAVE
SUPERVISION, THEY LEAVE THE
HOTEL AND THEN THEY END UP GOING
TO A RESTAURANT WHERE THEY ARE
COUGHING AND SNEEZING AND
EVERYBODY DOWN THERE IN TEXAS IS
SAYING, WHAT IS GOING ON.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS HAS A VERY
GOOD ARGUMENT THAT HE IS IN
CHARGE OF PROTECTING THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE CITIZENS OF
TEXAS.
HE’S NOT TRYING TO ENFORCE THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
WHAT HE’S TRYING TO DO IS
PREVENT COVID-INFECTED PEOPLE
FROM INFECTING THE MEMBERS OF
HIS STATE.
AND, OF COURSE, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD THINK
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION GIVEN
THAT THEY WANT TO MASK UP
AMERICAN CITIZENS WOULD AT LEAST
BE UNDERSTANDING ABOUT AND AG
SAYS THIS IS DANGEROUS FOR
GOVERNOR ABBOTT TO DO THIS.
THIS IS CRAZY, THIS IS CRAZY
TOWN.
RACHEL: IT’S COMPLETELY CRAZY.
I GET IT.
THE FEDS ARE IN CHARGE OF
IMMIGRATION AND OUR BORDER, BUT
WHAT I DON’T UNDERSTAND IS
LIBERALS HAD NO PROBLEM DEFYING
THE FED WHEN THEY WANTED
SANCTUARY CITY.
I LOOK AT TEXAS -- WHY DOESN’T
JUST TEXAS DO MORE?
ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY COULD
SAY WE WANT TO DO THIS, TEXAS
THINKS THEY ARE THEIR OWN
COUNTRY PRACTICALLY, WHY CAN’T
THEY DO MORE?
JEANINE: WELL, WHY CAN’T TEXAS
DO MORE IN BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WANTS ILLEGALS IN THE
-- IN THE COUNTRY AND THAT’S
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
IF THEY HAVE TO STOP A GOVERNOR
FROM PERFORMING HIS LAWFUL DUTY
OF PROTECTING HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ITS CITIZENS AND IT IS
EVIDENT THAT THEY’RE NOT
INTERESTED IN THE REALITY, THE
DATA, DR. SAPHIER JUST TALKED
ABOUT IT, THEN THE END GAME HERE
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE --
THAT WE HAVE TO WEAR A MASK --
MASKING PEOPLE IN CONGRESS, IT’S
CRAZY.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT
THIS WEEKEND ON MY SHOW.
I’M DOING AN INVESTIGATION OF
THE DELTA VARIANT AND I’M ALSO
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WHAT
PARENTS NEED TO KNOW BY A
HIGH-RANKING DEA OFFICIAL OF HOW
MUCH DANGER THEIR KIDS ARE IN
WITH FENTANYL CROSSING THE
BORDER, A LOT OF IT MADE IN
CHINA.
THIS IS A TAKEDOWN OF AMERICA
AND WE ARE LETTING IT HAPPEN OR
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS.
RACHEL: JUSTICE WITH JEANINE IS